hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
wählt heute backen wir zusammen diese
leckere muffins und zwar sei das
highlight muffins ich habe hier einen
richtig leckeren dunklen schokoladigen
muffin und darüber ist eine marshmallow
creme und die wir da noch getoppt mit
einem schokoladenüberzug also das ist
eigentlich wie so dickmanns aufnahmen
neuer fenster oder sagst du auch
deutsche sind muffins journey mohring
cockpits gesagt man hat dittmann muffins
und ich habe hier noch ein kleines bonus
rezept und zwar haben wir auch noch
leckere schoko profis gemacht und ich
zeige euch jetzt einfach ganz schnell
wie wir die zu bereiten
die muffins hinaus meinem grundrezept
zeit also ein grundrezept für den
schokoladen teig und ich zeige euch
jetzt schnell die zutaten für die
muffins verwende ich jetzt mein basis
grundrezept für die muffins zeige ich
aber trotzdem kurz die zutaten
ich habe 150 gramm weiche butter 150
gramm zucker etwas salz etwas vanille
extrakt 260 gramm mehl einen halben
teelöffel backpulver ein viertel
teelöffel natron 30 von kakaopulver
ich hab ich noch 100 gramm schoko trupps
und etwas milch und ich habe jetzt auch
hier schon einem av mit papier förmchen
ausgelegt und den ofen auf 145 grad ober
unterhitze vorgeheizt und ich mache das
jetzt ganz schnell
zuerst wird jetzt die butter mit dem
zucker dem salz und den ball exakt
verrührt
dann kommen noch die eier mit wein
jetzt gebe ich noch die trockenen
zutaten mit rein und da habe ich jetzt
hier auch schock trucks mit dabei die
sind jetzt beim basis grundrezept nicht
mehr dabei und eventuell noch etwas
milch
jetzt portioniert den teig das geht am
besten mit einem eislöffel und dann
werden die muffins bei 175 grad für etwa
20 minuten gebacken
die muffins sind jetzt abgekühlt und
jetzt kann ich diese marshmallow masse
zu bereiten
und dafür brauchen wir drei weiße 200
gramm puderzucker und einen halben
teelöffel weinstein backpulver und zwar
nehme ich da jetzt weinstein backpulver
weil da einfach kein phosphat drin ist
und haben später diesen backpulver
geschmack einfach nicht ihr könnt
natürlich auch normales benutzen aber
dann kann es eben passieren dass ich so
einen leichten beigeschmack gehabt und
jetzt braucht ihr eine schüssel am
besten eine metallschüssel die sollte
fettfrei sein also richtig schön sauber
staubfrei trocken und die setzt sich
jetzt in einen topf also innen heißes
wasser baut
da ergibt sich jetzt auch gleich das
wasser und hier gebe ich jetzt erstmal
die eiweiße rein und zwar wird die masse
jetzt mit zucker solange aufgeschlagen
mit hitze bis sie dann eben schön steil
ist und die hitze sorgt dann dafür dass
ich zum beispiel die krankheitserreger
abtöten kann also salmonellen usw und
damit aber auch dieser marshmallow masse
eben entsteht also ich ja weiß drin
dann kommt das puderzucker noch nicht
rein jetzt schalte ich den herd ein so
auf hohe hitze nicht ganz so hoch aus
mittelhof und rührt es jetzt erstmal gut
durch und so löst sich dann auch der
zucker richtig gut aus
und wenn ihr jetzt ein handrührgerät
habt könnt ihr auch das eiweiß direkter
drin steif schlagen
aber ich mache es jetzt kurz mit einem
schneebesen und rührt dann später mit
der küchenmaschine denn es musste also
etwa zehn minuten gehört werden
jetzt hat sich der zucker gut aufgelöst
gebe ich auch das backpulver direkt mit
rein und dann erhebt sich das ist
nochmal so etwa fünf minuten
und da ich jetzt kein normales android
gerät habe werde ich es jetzt gleich in
der küchenmaschine machen wenn ihr
übrigens eine küchenmaschine habt wie
zum beispiel die kenwood mit temperatur
könnte das auch direkt darin machen oder
wenn ihr bei der kitchenaid die
beheizbaren rücksitzen habt könnt ihr
auch die benutzten aber ich wollte
einfach noch zeigen wie man das eben
über dem wasserbad machen kann ich
erhitzt es jetzt so etwa fünf bis sieben
minuten und dann schlage ich das mit dem
mit der küchenmaschine steif
jetzt ist die masse richtig schön warm
und die schüssel ist sehr heiß ich gebe
ich sehe in der küchenmaschine und
schlagt sie dann steif und dadurch
vergrößert sich dann auch das volumen
also deswegen solltet ihr eine richtig
große schüssel nehmen
die marshmallows ist jetzt fest und
jetzt will ich sie in einen spritzbeutel
da habe ich schon eine spritztour drin
so eine ganz große loch schüler und
damit werde ich die muffins gleich
bespritzen
jetzt starte ich in der mitte und
arbeite mich dann von außen nach oben
ich stelle jetzt die muffins noch mal
kurz in den kühlschrank ich meine die
sind so schon richtig gut aus aber
richtig lecker werden zuerst wenn auch
die schokoladen klasse darüber kommt und
deswegen kann ich in der zwischenzeit
schon mal meine kuvertüre meine zeit
später kuvertüre temperieren
und dann stellen hat die muffins gleich
fertig ich habe jetzt hier 300 gramm
peter kuvertüre und die habe ich bereits
temperiert und gebt dann noch ein würfel
kokosfett mit rein also bei mir das
macht die schokolade etwas geschmeidiger
und das rühre ich jetzt noch kurz ein
und dann fühle ich die kuvertüre in ein
hohes gefäß ich nehme jetzt einfach ein
ganz normales trinkglas damit ich das
eben gut brauchen kann also damit die
muffins bot eintauchen kann
jetzt tue ich die ganz vorsichtig rein
müsst ihr darauf achten das ist einfach
gerade unterton dann kurz abtropfen
lassen und dann weg setzen
ich habe jetzt die muffins kühl gestellt
die müssen jetzt erst mal fest werden
und die restliche kuvertüre die
verbrauche ich jetzt noch gibt einfach
ein bisschen mandeln und komplex mit
dazu und kann so meine eigenen
schokokuss machen
diese schuld ich gucke jetzt schon
gegessen ist doch nicht schlimm
unsere schaumkuss muffins sind jetzt
fertig und auch die schoko groß ist denn
jetzt getrocknet also die schoko prosit
müsst ihr einfach nur bei
zimmertemperatur lagern oder wenn es
schneller gehen soll einfach im
kühlschrank und jetzt darf der murat
probieren wir spenden die der schatz
ich habe übrigens die muffins einfach
nur mal in schöne papier förmchen
gesetzt so könnte auch einfach
sichergehen dass es nicht durch fettet
und das einfach die form außen schön
bleibt und ich es auch im schoko bossi
ich geb dir schmecken ich genial
also ich finde auch super vor allem als
demokrat und samira die es jetzt von
oben runter ich würde wahrscheinlich
eher runter löffeln und wird hat dann
diese schaumkuss master mit dem machen
zusammen essen alles richtig mächtig ich
glaube nicht dass jemand mehr als zwei
stück schafft also einer reicht mir auch
offen ich voll witzig weil jetzt beide
so einen weißen schnauze habt am weißen
schnurrbart wäre dieses rezept nach
machen wollt geht einfach auf meinem
blog einfach einfach auf es half nichts
- blog.de da steht noch einmal das
genaue rezept schmeckt richtig gut in
schuss von de nicht korrekt morath wie
schaust du geleiten diesen politisch
korrekt sollen mit vollem mund spricht
man hat gestern ihre typische genau
ja also beide rezepte gibt's auf meinem
blog und ich wünsche euch ganz viel spaß
danach machen bis zum nächsten mal
tschüss jockey die große probiert euro
probiert
übrigens auch immer ein rezept geld mit
verschiedenen abwandlungen scorsese ist
gut
wenn man video fürst nachgemacht
original zu sehen wirklich super gau